well golden knight fans are still
talking about last night's big win over
the sharks thanks again to marc-andre
fleury
sports director chris matthews joins us
live here in the studio with more
on the flower chris that's right thank
you very much christian yeah i became a
show stopper here in the city of
entertainment marc-andre fleury
has been the best player on the ice for
many of the knights games so far this
season
he comes up with so many eye-popping and
acrobatic saves
that really nothing surprises you
anymore last night's save on that
breakaway was just another in a long
list of saves
that has his teammates talking flurry
definitely providing a script for what
may someday be an award-winning movie
the subject of the movie says hey don't
expect too much
i was sick mean
the dude is just the man i don't know
what else can you say like
me and rebo were talking about we want
to buy the rights to a
movie about him i don't think this movie
is going to be any good
this should just cancel that right now
but it's flattering very flattering here
but
yeah don't need it uh he is so humble
flory may get a break this week it looks
like
back up robin leonard is about to return
he's been suffering from that concussion
but
he's back with the team they play
against the kings this weekend
one raiders note according to nfl
network las vegas has cut three-time pro
bowler rodney hudson
clearly one of the best offensive
linemen in the league who played for six
years with the raiders
but an apparent cost cutting move hudson
was let go now four
of the five starting offensive linemen
in 2020
are now gone it's crazy